eu recebi um livro que falava da
história né numérico que se formou 100
anos antes de mim eu tô januário cicco e
falava de toda a luta dele de construir
a maternidade escola naquele passou mais
de 20 anos tentando é conseguir verbas
para que as mulheres do nosso estado ela
tivesse um local digno e seguro para dar
à luz
lembra aquela história eu me inspirei
nela e teve vontade de fazer alguma
coisa
eu sabia que não podia chegar e dizer
gente tá tudo errado né então realizei
uma pesquisa entregue 600 pessoas ao
longo do ano entre gestantes
profissionais acompanhantes e fui
estudando sobre o tema e fui me
apaixonando e descobri que já existe em
vários artigos científicos não é que a
ciência mais o que já provou a
importância desse momento a gente formar
uma criança que vai ser um bom cidadão e
eu levei esses resultados na época os
professores para a direção da
maternidade nem para a imprensa mas era
só um estudante de medicina que já
estava inclusive perto de concluir
saindo daquele estágio e eu não tenho
como fazer muita coisa não sabia que não
podia mudar um sistema é resolver os
problemas do sistema de saúde mudar uma
instituição hospitalar após a diretora
paixão eu estava sentindo naquele
momento mas aí veio a idéia eu não posso
mudar o sistema mas sim ensinar as
mulheres isso sim ensinar que o parta
delas é que elas podem ter um
acompanhante de sua escolha que elas
podem se preparar para aquele momento
para participar das decisões que estão
acontecendo ali e que eu falei pra elas
que naquele momento pode ser vivenciado
com sublimidade e aí eu encontrei
algumas amigas que toparam a ideia
sempre começou a fazer um grupo de
gestantes é pra tentar passar tudo isso
que eu tenho aprendido que estava com
muita vontade
é assim que se realizasse e a gente
começou a inserir os momentos com
arteterapia no meio dessas dessas rodas
de conversa
na poesia trabalhos manuais e eu me
lembre um dia chegou uma gestante nesse
grupo
e ela tem uma vida bem difícil já tinha
andado mais de dez crianças várias ações
assim não planejadas usava droga ficava
boa parte do tempo na rua e foi num
momento de uma poesia uma poesia que
falava do amor que existe entre mãe e
filho é essa mulher foi tocada né ela
chorou com toda a vida dela pra gente e
disse eu quero fazer diferente eu quero
ser uma mãe diferente
ela começou a freqüentar as reuniões e
eu vi o quanto a ar que ela era poderosa
nesses encontros o quanto ela poderia
trocar um imaginário tocava e aí nasceu
primeiro grupo do ar deve nascer e aí
essas crianças foram nascendo a gente já
era voltar nessa comunidade
alguns anos eu comecei a perceber que o
padrão de cuidar e que essas mulheres
estavam tendo era diferente do que a
gente vinha na comunidade
todo mundo amamentando tempo recomendado
levando para as consultas vacinas
atualizadas falavam que estavam contando
as histórias que aprendeu no grupo
cantando para os bebês e o nossa é o
idec um simples qualquer pessoa pode
fazer qualquer pessoa que tenha boa
vontade pode replicar no centro de saúde
ea nossa igreja na sua comunidade
aí veio a idéia de fazer um livro pra
que esse trabalho chegasse em outras
mãos
então esse foi o primeiro livro de arte
nascer dos encontros para formação de
saúde gestantes
o livro tem esse propósito é qualquer
pessoa que tenha boa vontade né
e queira cuidar e gestantes da sua
localidade possa replicar o projeto ea
gente teve notícia alguns meses depois
do lançamento do livro de alguns grupos
que surgiram em outros estados do brasil
motivados aí é pelo livro
no mesmo ano em que foi em 2010 é e
receber um link de um concurso que
estava acontecendo ele procurava idéias
inovadoras capazes de reduzir a
mortalidade materna a longo prazo na
área materno-infantil e aí alguém mandou
eu tenha um projeto inscreva eo projeto
se inscrevam neste concurso
assim olhei nossa mais de 40 países
competindo mais a 400 projetos inscritos
eu tinha cinco gestantes em um grupo 7 e
outro era um projeto ainda bem pequeno
nunca imaginei que o arteiro nascer
podia ganhar mas aí né
acabei ficando entre um dos 15
relacionados no doe da competição foi
onde sempre usava terno health
daí eu tive a oportunidade de conhecer
outras 14 pessoas que pensava igual a
mim é quando a gente assim se desvia um
pouco né dessa coisa mais tradicional do
meio médico você senta e muito sol e lá
eu a achei o meu lugar é todo mundo aqui
acredita que pode mudar o mundo também e
aí o desafio desse projeto é você vai
mudar e cultura mudar de local a gente
vai escolher um país pra você e você vai
passar nove meses para adaptar sua idéia
para o contexto desse novo país e
trabalhar com uma ong local para que
seus ideias fiquem depois que é você foi
embora e aí no país que eles escolheram
pra mim mali
eu nunca tinha ouvido falar antes de
receber o e mail com a passagem dizendo
pra onde eu ia e olha lá na internet que
era e eu chego lá no mali
e aí eu descobri uma realidade muito
diferente da que a gente tem aqui não
existe um sistema de saúde uma das
maiores mortalidades infantis do mundo
a mortalidade materna altíssima mulheres
têm acesso a métodos contraceptivos não
existe um pré natal gratuito não existia
um parto gratuito ea minha primeira
reação foi não vou fazer o aceiro na
sehac ward nasse ele é um complemento a
um sistema que eu acreditava que ainda
não era o ideal é um parto que eu
acreditava que ainda não é o ideal mas
eu não vou fazer não tem como fazer o
artigo nasci aqui e eu fui por outros
caminhos até encontrar nessa mulher que
está aí nessa falta comigo com bark foi
a minha mentora eu lembro quando eu
falei no projeto pra ela ela não é esse
que eu quero ver amanhã e você vai
começar com as mulheres da aldeia grupo
outro que adaptá lá ela não tá
entendendo nada que ele não serve pra cá
mas ali era eu que não estava entendendo
que realmente era a arte de nascer
então as reuniões foram acontecendo é a
gente foi entendendo quero que precisava
como é mudar na comunidade farão as
coisas que elas podiam fazer mudar
comportamento pratos e melhores
indicadores
durante a gravidez é depois com os
cuidados a crianças vamos fazendo os
momentos com arte principalmente em
atividades que pudessem disseminar
aquelas informações e o projeto foi
acontecendo e quando a gente chegou na
última reunião para ser expedido esse
grupo piloto
eu lembro até hoje das frases que eu
ouvi é que elas estavam se sentindo mais
mulheres mais dignas como ser humano as
pessoas melhores e depois participar do
ato de nascer
elas seriam mães melhores do que ela já
tinha sido que elas queriam transformar
a comunidade é formar crianças que iam
ser melhores cidadões para formar um
futuro diferente e aí eu entender que o
árbitro nascer não era um complemento
ele era um convite pra toda mulher se
tornar uma pessoa melhor para receber
uma criança e fazer com que essa criança
é seja mudança que a gente quer ver no
futuro
e aí eu escolhi nessa outra foto aí
mostrando em preto e branco que eu
queria que o projeto fosse replicado com
as adolescentes que tinham gestações não
planejadas
lá no mali é um grupo muito
negligenciado
essas meninas se elas ficam grávidas
fora de um casamento elas são renegados
né pelas suas aldeias pelas suas
famílias não têm ninguém para ocupar a
acolher
elas ligam para as grandes cidades é
geralmente ficam na rua não consegue
emprego
algumas morrem porque é um local tão
difícil se você não tiver ajuda a chance
de você morrer é muito alta
outras não e seus bebês para adoção
outros jogam em seus bebês no lixo e eu
decidi que eu queria com arte nasceu
fosse replicado com esse grupo e foi bem
interessante meu primeiro encontro com
ela já estava com os facilitadores
também queriam replicar o
já após a minha saída e eu lembro que
elas chegavam nem sem nenhum brilho no
olhar sem nenhuma perspectiva de futuro
e eu não sei como é que eu vou conseguir
me conectar com elas e ensinar é assim
toda gestação ela pode ser vivenciada
com amor com alegria com sublimidade e
aí veio a idéia near their de novo aí
tocando da fotografia a gente distribuiu
nas câmeras e dava algum tempinho pra
elas fotografaram que elas quisessem que
representasse que elas queriam para o
futuro e elas voltavam todas sorrindo
felizes em mostrar e explicar cada foto
ea partir daí a gente começava a
construir né todo o vínculo
e aí eu voltei né então me adaptar
depois pra vida normal e vou falar um
pouco de como votar o projeto hoje então
existe alguns grupos
desde 2008 que continua funcionando nem
natal em alguns locais da grande natal
a gente faz essa união do conhecimento
científico das boas práticas que podem
ser adotadas nem aí prevenção com essa
união de poesia de música nery outros
tipos de arte aqui é uma foto do grupo
que trabalhou no lançamento pra gente é
confeccionar lançar o segundo livro
artevila nascer para mães e bebês que
reúne nerds conhecimentos científicos
uma coletânea de poemas e um cd de
canções de ninar né que então tudo isso
a gente acaba trabalhando nos grupos que
a gente tem alguns anos o projeto passou
a ser replicado no instituto santos
dumont é vinculado ao mec e há dois anos
atrás ele foi institucionalizar faz
parte de um dos programas desenvolvidos
pelo instituto e o instituto recebe
muitos alunos várias profissões de saúde
para fazer estágio lá e foi esse
professor que sempre acreditou em todas
as idéias que eu levei que até então pra
isso e falou
o projeto tem grande potencial de ajudar
esses profissionais a desenvolver vários
valores várias habilidades é que a gente
quer que os profissionais da área de
saúde tenho então hoje em dia com o
daria duarte na seca
a festa da semana todo mundo pára para
os profissionais
os alunos de seis cursos diferentes da
área de saúde às gestantes a gente senta
tem roda de conversa depois todo mundo
faz a a atividade de arteterapia junto e
as pesquisas com esses alunos mostram
enquanto o projeto está ajudando os a
desenvolver empatia fortalecer a relação
médico-paciente ressignifica essa
relação profissional de saúde paciente
que às vezes é tão distante ajudando
esses alunos a entrar em contato com a
comunidade contribuindo com a formação
de responsabilidade social né ea em 2015
projeto foi vencedor de outra competição
internacional chamada projetos do ator
que há uma foto da gente
apresentando o projeto na áfrica do sul
e foi uma competição que procurava
projetos inovadores que estava
transformando o que era capaz de
transformar a educação das profissões de
saúde
e aí também a gente entendeu que não
basta cuidar das crianças no período
entre o término é que esse cuidado ele
precisa continuar e o artigo nascer hoje
também a escola até três anos atrás de
fundar o centro infantil artrite nas e
que tem uma educação toda baseada em
valores humanos e parte dessas crianças
que estudam a hoje foram crianças que
frequentaram os grupos gestantes quando
estavam dentro da barriga das mães no
período entre o terreno e tem sido uma
experiência que a gente tem aprendido
muito e também tem feito a gente se
apaixonar
ainda mais pelo tema eu nunca imaginei
né quando eu tive aquela inquietação não
estava naquele estágio que o artigo
nascer iria me leva aonde me levou iria
tomar conta do meu coração depois da
minha vida
nério em fazer para vários locais do
mundo
e quando eu penso por que isso aconteceu
né porque deu tudo certo porque tudo foi
se encaixando porque as pessoas certas
foram aparecendo e eu acho que é porque
ele é sobre o amor né esse amor
existem entre mãe filho e que é tão
pouco ainda inexplorado por parte de
cada um de nós
eu queria agradecer eu nunca imaginei
também biota participando do evento como
esse falando do projeto queria deixar
aqui o meu agradecimento e
principalmente queria agradecer a todas
as mulheres que um dia já partilharam
desse amor que existe entre mãe e filho
comigo nesses encontros e como o projeto
nettheim arte desde o nome que recitou
um trecho do poema do livro
para finalizar foi escrito pela poetisa
briga do ar e queria dedicar ao filho
que eu voltei em breve que agora estava
ensinando na prática né esse amor que eu
já tinha compartilhado com tantas
pessoas que seja bem bita em mim esta
vida ela sublimidade que é gerar um
filho ligado entrelaçado desde umbigo
até as pétalas do coração que seja
bendito em mim esta vida em que o amor é
magistralmente farto em um momento
íntimo do parto quando eu finalmente
puder conhecer o rosto do filho que
evitei haverá de se perceber pintada com
uma estrela na tela no céu
a arte ele nascer muito obrigado
[Aplausos]